[Music]
there's warm air look at this and that's
how I got to three 6s Daniel left out
one fundamental secret the Muslim people
always told me I should write a book
about the comedy of errors that is my
life I made a movie instead prefer dad I
hinted the world alongside my twin
sister with her a new set of head /
something my parents hasn't called to
build a comfortable setting for us we
moved home a lot my imagination told me
that I could roll the helicopter in the
backyard out of dirt which I'd worked on
for months my dad's friend Steve thought
it will be hilarious to [ __ ] with
operations I didn't think so
attending a junior school where all the
kids spoke Afrikaans besides me left me
pretty lonely and I had no friends no
cable TV and got Tucker's during every
rectifies
even bubbling Tina's but for me it was
awesome I love being alone in my own
head going on epic journeys and the
ethical things I started surfing through
long blond locks a very huge head and
got beaten up I moved to a small town
called chromakey and joined a gang well
like a naughty surfer at group called
17-3 where our tours or all kinds of
truck starting a TV ad for McDonald's
which square saw people making these
first time my ticket to the big league
awed by camera and made found outer
wasn't that easy after failing to make
anything that looked like a bit on the
big screen I started smoking cigarettes
and drinking Oh God
I was a kid you would see standing in a
group and immediately label arrogant
thinking I had this fire burning inside
of me which told me that I'll be rich
and famous one day my grades was [ __ ] my
twin sister was excelling while I lived
in a hut in shadow but something deep
down would keep telling me that I was a
gift from God at the sunshine for my
rear I continued to live in a fantasy
world fueled by the words of little
Wayne at the time I got rid of my video
camera editing laptop to buy an
expensive gift for go fun enough jr. to
go broke my heart to purchase empowering
a party
to speak the local language so they took
advantage of the situation locked me up
with a manipulative the story and ended
in Atlantic drugs on me I was able to
escape in the South African embassy so I
flew back to Bali and got a kiss marks
tattoo on my back because I thought I
was the new microscope over there blue
home started film school where they try
to mold me into the perfect little film
director I despise 80 bucks anyone try
to put me in so I said some ridiculous
price those who can do do and those who
can't teach
they didn't like that it was base for me
to quit by myself broke with nothing to
show for the past 20 years
my family was over me and I didn't have
any real friends boohoo you know Dan
maybe I can get you a warm bowl of
cry-baby soup you know I'm seeing a
pattern emerge here let me explain it
sounds like you're waiting for something
like waiting for life to hand you a
golden ticket you're waiting for some
lucky break
some pot of gold and here in the rainbow
because in this world this [ __ ] doesn't
exist
there's a little bit dramatic
but how's about this Thomas Edison say
the quotes often opportunity is missed
as disguise and overalls and looks like
work so I got a tattooed on my arm
just imagine living life with that
mindset every single day in my mind
opportunity doesn't exist it's called
work and it's on every corner of every
[ __ ] Street hey what about that all
right I see where you're going keep keep
going there I changed everything about
myself except that fire that kept
burning in me I started my first company
called if not why not
that looks at the world of content
through new eyes I ran it into the
ground so I quit I started a YouTube
channel made my first for you started
suffering with depression and anxiety
but useful making as an outlet to
transcend through the burdens on my
conscious mind
I created a mirror character for myself
called gift and won my first big award
which got me noticed assigned to my
first production I won two awards at
count got rated as one of six of the
best young film directors in the world
by shots magazine directed a TV
commercial that changed the perception
of an entire African country moved to a
new production house where I won another
award at Cannes the bridge started
getting involved and I got big-headed
which led me to look at my teenage self
in the mirror again I needed change look
Tirana perv little box I printed house
go for it
sausage dog parents my twin sister
everything that makes my
but being comfortable scares the [ __ ]
out of me around this time Casey sent me
this message you know Danny said you
should seriously consider coming to New
York City I think you could do great
things here and then I reacted with this
message
this went on for about a month until I
say I'm moving to you
most people doubts in my decision
because I become a traditional thinker a
qualified TV commercial director and
shouldn't downgrade to a youtuber what
does this even mean that I get to stand
on some pretentious Island high-fiving
everyone with a nametag no I choose to
rather join the [ __ ] tidal wave of
young minded creators and changemakers
on YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
and don't worry about those
[ __ ] people are always jealous
of someone who has the gumption to go
for it in life because those the people
who don't have the gumption to go for it
life like one truth I learned very early
in my career is that people who have
surrendered their dreams those the
people who love to discourage people
like you from chasing your dreams so I
packed my things and came to a city that
makes me feel smaller than I've ever
felt that's not an opportunity that's a
decision swimming off that Island wasn't
easy but it helped me find my purpose in
filmmaking again and that's how I got
2/3 success I'm not saying it's the
right way it's definitely not the only
way but that was my journey here I know
I'm always complaining and it seems like
a lot of work and that I'm always tired
but at the end of the day I've been a
part of making 30 films in 30 days they
were 31 31 films in 31 days and I've
never felt so fulfilled
waking up with extreme purpose every
morning
[Music]
loco
I guess that was my first video here in
New York when to the next video in New
York no you're supposed to say subscribe
yeah don't forget to smash that like
button and subscribe and subscribe to
danceOn oh I don't know I don't think
they'll believe that dude it feels like
as if I told you you know no they'll
believe it no you gotta say it from your
heart don't forget to subscribe to dance
channel and like that smash button
[Laughter]
[Music]